jacques est maintenant donnée milk bush
donnelly creusement soir vous êtes
journaliste auteur d'un ouvrage
d'investigation denquête document
biographie et vous publié aux éditions
numéro un un livre qui savait didier
deschamps vainqueurs dans l'âme qui est
consacré au capitaine des bleus c'est
qu'on fait
faire donc oui dit deschamps capitaine
de l'équipe de france et gagner le
mondial qui a gagné l'euro 2000
évidemment pourquoi lui pourquoi pas
choisi dany les plus glamour que lui non
barthez les ans parce que zidane avait
déjà écrit sa biographie
j'allais perdre en écrasant deuxième lui
parce que je trouvais que c'était il
avait l'image d'un anti héros d'une anti
star c'était quelqu'un d'assez
énigmatique et je me suis dit c'est un
joueur qui a le plus gros palmarès du
football français qui a été capitaine de
l'équipe de france pendant dix ans qui a
été capital de toutes les formations
dans lesquels il a joué
et pourtant quand on le voit comme ça
c'est vrai qu'ils payent pas de mine
mais je me suis dit je saisis mais c'est
vrai en même temps mais bon j'avoue il
n'est pas de répit paul il est passé au
péage de l'autoroute on fait attention à
lui
il meurt fait bulletin enfin quelques
uns quand même il en a marqué quatre
dans sa carriole sais pas où en buteur
voilà et je me suis dit mais qu'est ce
que choisit d'en tuer roquois lantieri
qui mangent bien les gâteaux je trouve
un bon mangeur de gâter
mais comme cette année noire au début
c'était pas du tout d'accord c'est
quelqu'un de très discret et atroce
alors comment ça s'est passé mais je
l'appelais un jour j'ai réussi à voir
son numéro de portable par sa maman que
je remercierai jamais assez et je savais
et je les appelais je connaissais pas du
tout et j'ai dit allô bonjour didier
deschamps je m'appelle dominique roux je
suis journaliste écrit un livre sur vous
hélas un grand blanc et il m'a dit je ne
suis pas d'accord j'ai l'habitude de
tout maîtriser dans la vie je ne veux
pas écrire de livres je ne participe
réparé et je sais pas pourquoi je me
suis acharné je me suis obstinée jusqu'à
obtenir un rendez vous avec lui où il
m'a dit non et puis par la force
finalement vous avez fait là dit le
maintenant alors elle est arrivée en
colombie les cheveux gras non jeu
les convaincus qu'ils méritaient un
livre je me suis acharné j'utilisais
n'importe quel prétexte pour l'appeler
et puis après je me suis un peu adressée
à sa mère et puis après sa femme avant
l'a beaucoup aidée mais toute la famille
d'encercler en fait une stratégie
d'encerclement et je l'appelais pour ne
rien lui dire je trouvais des prétextes
et au fil du temps il a fini par se
dérider et à accepter le bouquin mais
j'ai ramé je ne sais pas c'est comment
vous êtes-vous souvent comment ça se
passait jamais voulais pas me parler ah
ben non alors qu pas ce que j'ai fait
j'ai interviewé ses parents j'ai
interviewé sa femme et j'ai interviewé
les joueurs l'équipe de france tous les
gens qui avaient jalonné sa carrière et
temps en temps au téléphone il daigné me
donner comme ça quelques confidences à
bord oui ça se voit pas bien ce livre
c'est arrivé très bien informé ah mais
j'ai bossé s'est passé du temps
[Musique]
que je
sans toi didierjean
je vais le faire
en fait
merci merci pour lui
on méritait beaucoup plus évidemment
vous êtes le footballeur français le
plus titré
l'un des footballeurs mondiaux les plus
titrés aussi de ligue des champions l'om
en 93 l'ag 28 196 champion de france 90
92 champion d'italie 95 97 98 coupe
d'italie 95-97 coupe d'angleterre avec
chelsea en 2006 champion du monde en 98
champion d'europe en 2000
recordman des sélections 103 matches
avec les bleus et recordman des matchs
comme capitaine 53 sélections mesdames
messieurs un triomphe romain un triomphe
on a associé consécration ultime ici
nous sommes
et
merci à tous didier deschamps donc alors
le seul problème vous ai jamais eu la
coupe de france
j'ai jamais joué de finale non la seule
année où j'aurais pu la jouer c'était
malheureusement lors des incidents de
furiani un été en demi finale et donc
j'ai pas eu la chance de jouer je me
coupe de france non à bombay tournée
prochain les années en corse à se
coucher pop the way
alors désormais bien vous êtes
reconverti depuis que vous avez quitté
dans les produits laitiers
mais en sport et en fait c'est le
discret michel additionner les biscuits
salés
vous êtes un vrai signe un ballon joué à
valence mais pourquoi valence pourquoi
être les jouer à valence pourrait pas en
france pour revenir en france il faut
être deux il faut que moi j'ai le vague
ouais je le voulais mais bon il n'ya pas
des clubs qui l'ont voulu donc le vrai
nom c'est difficile pour que ce que
c'est que cette histoire n'est pas un
club qui vous a voulu j'ai eu des
contacts mais bon c'est difficile avec
un titre de champion du monde et tout
cela que ça représente vrai que c'est
pas c'est pas évident
pour les clubs français à l'heure
actuelle c'est pratiquement impossible
de refaire de faire revenir un champion
de la mort oui alors vous êtes en plus
de sa consultant et animateur sur tps
dans une émission qui s'appelle des
champs contrechamps malin et alors vous
avez quoi carte blanche pour parler de
foot c'est ça donc soit vous voulez oui
c'est un magazine
entre 20 et 25 minutes où je reviens sur
l'actualité du football de la semaine et
puis j'ai un invité au téléphone pendant
une dizaine de minutes en général un
joueur ou un entraîneur puis quelques
petits retour sur la carrière ainsi du
match en équipe de france fut animateur
télé quoi
ouais un peu comme vous et vous avez un
site internet dont le numéro apparaît en
bas de l'écran alors c'est quoi ce site
c'est pouvoir de vos nouvelles pour way
pour communiquer avec avec le public et
les fans je crois que ça permet de
répondre en direct d'avoir contact un
peu plus proche et lorsqu'on est à
l'étranger
c'est moins évident que lorsqu'on joue
dans un club français donc ça permet
d'être toujours en courant de
l'actualité du joueur bien alors on va
parler un petit peu de
alors dominique si des fois il dit pas
la vérité je compte sur vous un pour
corriger un maintenant vous le
connaissez très bien
donc j'étais en 68 à bayonne au pays
basque jusque là tout va bien dans un
milieu ouvrier
votre mère de travail de 7 heures du
matin à sept heures du soir comme
vendeuse et votre père il est peintre à
l'aérodrome de biarritz il travailler
les samedis et dimanches donc ça bossait
beaucoup j'ai des gens à payer pour
gagner un peu plus d'argent il avoue
tout balayer la maison
voilà entre autres comme nous tous alors
vous manqué de rien mais pas de superflu
quoi oui ça vous a donné des bonnes
bases tout ça de certains repères vous
allez valeurs je fais dans la famille
les valeurs familiales
l'homme du pays basque enfin voila c'est
assez carré comme mec quoi on peut
appeler ça comme ça ouais peu un peu
têtu quoi oui très justement comme vous
êtes base quand j'étais petit vous allez
à là à la chasse à la pêche comme ça
avec votre père et un jour ils sont
venus vous voir pour le parti pêche
chasse et traditions et vous embarquer
je vous avais pas compris que c'est un
parti vous lorsque servi ce soir mais
bien sûr jean st gelais enrôler oui tout
à fait dit non je participe pas ça c'est
vrai que j'ai défend ses idées afin
d'aider le fait de la page la pêche la
chasse la nature je suis quelqu'un de
très nature mais hors de question de ne
participer à un parti politique
et puis dans leur liste de brengues
d'une des chambres en plus sa voix des
électeurs sans doute quoi donc
alors l'état voulait pas en parler le t1
non c'est pas un sujet que j'ai envie de
brel non c'est suffisamment grave et
puis du fait de mon image publique il
vaut mieux pas faire de commentaire
parce que ce sera toujours mal
interprétés je vous ai pas peur je vais
pas dire que j'ai peur mais lorsque je
je vois ce qui est arrivé à mon ami
bixente lizarazu c'est vrai que ça porte
à réfléchir et je suis surtout très
triste pour lui et j'espère ne jamais
connaître cette situation
est ce que c'est quand même un peu la
terreur là c'est à dire que vous pouvez
pas vous exprimer
parce que vous avez peur de représailles
sur votre famille ce qu'ils font pas
régner la terreur ben si oui il ya la
terreur il ya la peur je m'exprime mais
bon en tant que j'ai une image publique
je préfère ne pas m'exprimer banderas
aussi vous avez parlé de lizarazu et à
banderas aussi qui oui je sais je savais
que ça serait bien
bon alors on continue votre gilet et
fait des études collège catholique à
bayonne
j'étais doué en maths et en physique
mais vous dites y avait pas un fait du
foot j'aurais pu le faire la gestion et
l'écologisme ans que j'avais certaines
facilités
j'ai continué continuer après par la
suite moi j'ai dû m'arrêter pour
incompatibilité avec le football
alors pourquoi au pays du rugby faisait
choisi le foot je pense c'est venu
naturellement j'ai joué au rugby aussi
ça me plaisait mais je me sentais plus à
l'aise avec un avec un ballon parce que
mes camarades les plus proches et jouer
au football donc pour rester avec eux je
joue au football vous commencé très tôt
une première licence à l'âge de 12 ans
assez tard avant vous trouvez ça tu as
repris par rapport à mardi s'en sort
toujours pas commencé à l'heure actuelle
est assise en ces temps ils sont déjà
avant dans des clubs
avec des parents qui les harcèle au bord
du terrain qu'attendent à l'âge de 7 ans
au bord du terrain signée par an qui
pousse le papa qui voudrait que c'est
absolument footballeur idée des
éducateurs qui sont pas toujours quand
votre père vous demande pourquoi vous
n'allez pas jouer aux genêts d'anglet
vous dit aucun joueur pendant d'algues
vertes dont va être vexant votre père
quand votre père vous demande pourquoi
vous n'allez pas jouer aux genêts
d'anglet 8 aucun joueur n'est jamais
sorti de la base j'étais déjà vachement
motivé parce que déjà dès le départ vous
prenez l'aviron bayonnais est pas les
genêts d'anglet
oui aujourd'hui parce que souvent c'est
tendance à dire anglais et d'attention
vous allez revenir à la barre suite de
ces passants aux genêts d'anglet mais
dès le début
voilà dès le début vous visez la
réussite non mais non je pensais pas je
sais pas pourquoi je me rappelle avoir
dit ça mais pourtant un pour moi le
football c'était pas c'était pas un
métier je voyais pas ça comme parvenir
professionnel c'était un jeu mais bon
tant qu'à prendre une licence et être
dans un club autant gagner autant ou
aller dans une équipe qui prennent qui
prennent pas des raclées tous les
week-ends
j'aimais pas pernes donc à partir de là
j'ai su dès votre plus jeune âge vous
détestez père dit l'important c'est pas
de jouer c'est de gagner si vous êtes
anti coubertin grèce a changé ma
doctrine est joué pour jouer pour gagner
et du plaisir à travers la victoire mais
comme j'étais petit les gens disent
c'était haineux quand vous perdiez sa
théorie vous parliez pas aux autres leur
faisait la gueule vous les traitez
caveau rude comme il dit chez moi ça va
j'ai la tête à enfourner je te piquer
des crises non mais insupportable
mauvais joueurs puisque ça et là vous
avez perdu une finale de coupe
d'aquitaine je posséde être les manifs
vous pleuré après ça vous déchets ça
vous touche est vraiment horreur de la
défaite vous faisiez des prières pour
gagner non maintenant à faisait à
l'époque
après l'arrêté mais l'arrêté quand votre
foi la mort vous aussi j'aime et j'ai
changé un peu dans l'attitude je suis
catholique mais bon je suis pas pratique
je dois un croyant qu avant vous voyez
plus au destin cadieux maintenant car
oui tout à fait décent pour taper une
salle à quoi bon alors ensuite vous
partez en formation à nantes un bas à
bordeaux il faut dire que les mecs de
bordeaux baisse des coûts j'étais venu
chez vos parents en limousine il des
cigares des grosse mallette et en disant
à votre père quand même vous voulez pour
votre fils est vrai que c'est pas très
élégant sont impressionnants ouais c'est
vrai souvent beaucoup de vagues lions
mais c'est mon grand père qui disait ça
ouais mon avis c'est des vrais
maquignons mais ça donne est tout à fait
cette image là comme j'en ai acheté un
bon petit vous le nourrir et puis s'il
est pas bon on vient acheter uniquement
morse après c'est fini mais si ça marche
pas après c'est dur donc vous allez à
nantes
et là c'est dur parce que vous retrouvez
à l'âge de 14 ans seule dans cette
grande ville puis en plus ce centre de
formation j'imagine que d'émulation donc
c'est la jeanne lanvin il faut pas voir
on a une image un peu dorée du centre de
formation puis moi je suis arrivé j'ai
eu la malchance qu'on ait parlé beaucoup
de moi comme est présenté comme la
future star et je suis arrivé à 15 ans
il y avait d'autres joueurs entre 15 et
18 ans ils me l'ont fait payer un petit
peu qua non mais bon ça fait depuis j'ai
été accepté après c'est comme ça il faut
savoir se bat vous apprenez à vous
déplacer dans tous les cas là bas et
puis au bout de mon dû commencer à
prendre des cuites avec eux ça devient
plus sympa non une surtout mémorable la
grande scène théâtre depuis vont
rencontrer marcel desailly oui voilà qui
est devenu votre votre grand ami par la
suite donc c'est sûr alors déjà la base
j'étais capitaine au centre de formation
vous êtes vraiment un leader né non
c'est un chef
je sais pas où ça s'est fait
naturellement je l'aurai ce qu'il faut
être pour être chef mais bon partout où
je suis passé on m'a confié des
responsabilités dès le début vous avez
été habitué à être en contact avec la
presse et que les médias de par la même
qu'au départ le savais pas où j'étais au
devant de la scène donc à partir de là
j'ai très vite compris comment
fonctionnaient les médias alors là on
arrive à la fiche 69
non mais c'est une tradition dans cette
émission et les rôles sont inversés
évidemment donc c'est vous qui allez me
poser une question j'ai une question
indiscrète j'ai une rumeur que j'ai
entendu ce que je voudrais savoir si
c'est une légende
est ce que c'est vrai que vous ne
portait ni caleçon ni un slip
ouais c'est vrai
lesquels sont islip ya ceux qui voient
la servante livré quelque chose il va
être bien votre émission son tps qui
descendent en crachant à votre premier
match procès contre brest à 16 ans et
demi
vous n'êtes pas très doué techniquement
n'ont-ils cadix attendait c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'ai vu dans tous les
nombreux articles que j'ai lu on dit que
vous êtes un bon dribble pas bon de la
tête
vous avez une frappe qui est pas très
puissante oui elle était au départ mais
ça ne va pas ça me sert pas que ça ça ne
sert pas spécialement besoin de faire
des ailes de pigeon et sesat 1 de trucs
ces gens me disent on j'étais pas un
surdoué j'ai beaucoup travaillé mais
j'aime pas l'aisance d'un zidane thierry
henry je peux à l'attaquant qua non non
vraiment pas non je l'étais quand
j'étais jeune je marquais beaucoup de
buts ah bon oui je te là vous avez dit
combien de buts 4 en équipe de france en
équipe de france juniors que 22 23 24
but de ma carrière pour le moment pas
spécialement plus ça va moins ça va plus
ça va plus je vais finir derrière le
gardien entraîneur d'almeria va bien je
peux plus
votre génie c'est le placement dont vous
avez toujours une fois et c'est ça ça
fait partie de mon jeu mais bon le
football se joue quand même avec les
pieds dedans c'est pour ça que l'on dit
que bon je suis pas très technique
s'il temps je dois mettre le ballon à
gauche on va toujours à droite je voyais
des problèmes quand même quoi on a
reproché que je récupérerai beaucoup de
ballons que j'en perdais beaucoup ci
avait au fil du temps ça s'est amélioré
mais bon j'arrive quand même à faire
obéir sur le ballon mais il sera fier
bien ce terrain sont pas des scellés
on l'amène au stade y peut y aller tous
j'ai une oreillette j'ai une oreille à
ses gros progrès depuis brest ça c'est
un truc qu'on apprend dans le bouquin
c'est que vous êtes un sacré de valeur
en fait c'est vrai quand on voit ça en
fait de très bonne heure c'est un truc
sont bien on découvre pas avec les
médias mais un bossu ça va la savane
particulier je réponds pas des questions
de football donc à voir avec moi il n'y
a pas de danger à 20 ans vous êtes
capitaine de nantes est alors la même
saison vous êtes vous êtes sélectionné
pour la première fois dans les bleus qui
sont à l'époque coaché par un parent
platini oui alors platini vous a dit un
truc sur les comment aller chercher un
trophée moi j'adore cette histoire ce
qui vous a dit il faut prendre son temps
il a raison on m'a dit beaucoup de
choses à dire mais prend le temps parce
que c'est possible qu'ils à rouen n'est
ce pas oui encore ce même plaisir
il a raison mais j'ai eu la chance de
connaître assez souvent quand même mais
bon il faut prendre le plaisir passé
rêve vraiment un plaisir d'arriver au
bout de gagner une coupe c'est beaucoup
de boulot ça serait bon comme ça y est
je trouve c'est vrai que quand on reçoit
un trophée
vous aurez vous aurez votre molière
break oui quand on reçoit un trophée on
y va toujours en venir c'est un an tiger
woods 35 ans je n'aime pas apprécié
apprécier chaque pas il faut savourer
oui bon avoir sa bombe tout le monde
vous le dis quoi il a il n'a pas été
très simple avec vos platines et c'est
ce qu'on me dit mais pourquoi je sais
pas si c'est
moi j'ai de bons rapports avec lui c'est
quelqu'un que je respecte énormément que
j'ai jamais voulu critiquer parce qu'il
n'est pas critiquable pour moi mais bon
pourtant quand je le vois quand il est
toujours le sourire que devant vous il
la ramène pas non je le chambre mois 1,1
privé quoi je me gêne pas non plus mais
ça s'arrête là alors il a dit que
j'étais un joueur peu spectaculaire sans
génie pas un grand joueur
aussi les jaloux parce qu'il n'a jamais
je suis demandé ce que j'espère pas si
l'année à être jaloux michel platini par
rapport à tout ce qu'il a fait j'ai déjà
aidé d'autres joueurs qu'ils soient
aigris et jaloux je peux le comprendre
sans citer de nom n'est que michel
platini sur comme ça non pour moi c'est
pas vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous que d'étudier le problème pendant
de longs mois
jalousie aussi dominique rocher d'accord
avec moi bon après tout est vendu à l'om
aura j'adore le toujours le côté mac
ligne ont été jetés ils vous disent ils
vous disent à un andy vous dites on a
vendu didier ce sera marseille j'avais
besoin d'argent l'époque il était en
difficulté et société le président le
regretté max bouyer et il m'a appris ça
oui on sort d'un match en équipe de
france que je joue à toulouse vendus
voilà vous arrivez à mars évidemment il
ya tapie alors lui en plus ils croient
pas en vous c'est au départ vous
apprêtez à bordeaux oui après six mois
après parce que j'ai eu un départ
fulgurant et après un peu le trou noir
étaient présents étaient vendus à
marseille marseille le président de
l'endroit où vous rira mais aussi appris
qu'ils voulaient pas que je revienne
ouais c'est ça surtout bien sûr quand
vous revenez je montais s'est prêté
bernard tapie lui dit chez moi tu
réussiras pas vaut mieux que tu partes
sympa comme d'hab c'est ce qu'il pensait
s'ils n'arrivaient pas de l'avait pas vu
ou su puisque humains après qu'un humain
il m'a redonné ma chance c'est qu'au
fond de lui et vous est déjà couché deux
battus j'ai discuté avec lui pendant une
heure mais je me suis accrochée et a
franchi jeudi parce que pour moi à
partir du moment où j'avais signé un
contrat l'om
il est hors de question il fallait que
je me pose alors sur ça c'était clair et
donc je suis revenu puis mais a pris ma
il m'a facilité la tâche quand même il
m'a donné ma chance je suis à bas prix
vous imposer que desailly d'ailleurs et
puis vous finissez capital et puis après
la coupe d'europe des clubs champions à
munich
jusque là tout va bien auprès des oem
verra évidemment là c'est moins drôle
c'est donc grâce à un petit peu si
c'était mon âge était au milieu quand
même des rentrées d'argent quand même
donc en mba et puis l'histoire de la
coupe du monde 94 quoi oui moi j'étais
au parc des princes mois ci à kenner la
section mettez les manteaux mais à ce
moment là que vous avez le nier et en
fin de partie 1 puisqu'il cet intérêt
d'acheter les billets pour les éternels
ballon et c'était costaud d'inaki la
partie c'est une terrible y avait des
gens qui étaient pas en bleu blanc rouge
comme ça que ses larmes qui coulaient
sur le bleu blanc rouge et où c'était
une image d'une forme c'était terrible
pour vous 20 pour nos joueurs s'étaient
inscrits cinq autres auraient matisse -
ça restera un ordre matériel que ce sont
dix neuf bien celui-là et là comme par
hasard c'est bon on peut pas les plus
bas donc c'est le début de la remontée
avec avec jacques est oui alors d'abord
ces cantonales capitaine des bleus 1
jusqu à crystal palace que ce qu'il
fasse ses bêtises ouais je veux c'est
possible je sais qu'il faut si vous
allez bien non je sais qu'il a fait des
bêtises et si on parlait de vous
l'appréciez beaucoup d'arrivées bien sûr
comme toute valeur comme être humain
comme l'acteur le fait d'un arrêt qu il
laisse pas indifférent comme amy des
mois tous
cantona pour main sur mac sans moi
j'aime bien quand max max en bon alors
jacques et apprécié votre charisme vous
remplacez donc cantona disons qu'il a eu
des discussions avec eric cantona il
avait des choses à faire et à partir du
moment où il n'a pas prié rick il a dû
s'appuyer sur un sur une autre personne
il a fait le tour un peu des anciens et
puis m'a confié le brassard de capitaine
non mais nous a raconté quand on n'a
tiré que quand jackie est allé voir en
angleterre il était dans une fête il a
fait attendre jacquet pendant deux
heures c'est vrai bon ben voilà après
zidane djorkaeff remplace cantona papa
sur l'euro 96 et la grande équipe de
france se met à penser à l'explication
ouais et non pas le fait que je sens mon
capitaine ouais cantona vous savez vous
qu'il ait fait virer quand même non ah
non j'ai pas ce pouvoir là non parce que
quand vous traitez de porteur d'eau oui
mais j'ai pensé l'eau pour lui pendant
cinq ans donc c'est pas
la vendée
sort pourra jamais l'oublier en étant là
on est en paix aurez vous aussi
mais bon on était même moi qui n'aime
pas le football du tout je me suis prise
jeudi aux genres et des demi-finales et
tout ça à klaxonner dans la voiture
comme une andouille alors que j'aurais
trouvé ça stupide six mois avant et
c'est vrai on était tous avec vous je
pas pourquoi tous les jours que vous
pensez être réunies il a bien senti
c'est la première fois depuis de chemin
depuis la libération de malgré ça vous
êtes très critiqué sur la préparation de
l'euro 2000
vous décidez de plus parler à la presse
pendant le championnat d'europe oui
c'est ça mais c'est pas simplement les
critiques les critiques elles ont
utilisé toujours acceptées elles font
partie du métier comme on dit mais
lorsqu'on en arrive à ça soit des
articles malsain ou avoir jusqu'à
l'incompétence bon cela ne m'intéressait
pas de répondre à certaines personnes
malheureusement c'était pas la majorité
des journalistes et je le regrette bien
qu'il faut le dire en particulier oui
mais ce sont certains va tous les
journalistes de l'équipe astana qui sont
bons aussi quoi s'est pas améliorée un
certain wii qui ont mal fait leur
travail ou qui ont cherché à et comment
après la victoire que vous aviez obtenu
avec l'équipe de france à la coupe du
monde
comment dans les années qui ont suivi
vous pouvez être autant critiqué les
guignols qu'on remette une couche
comme le dit si bien aimé jacquet
comment non mais comment ça se fait
comment vous expliquez ça vous l'image
des guignols bon je pensais jamais y
être parce que j'avais pas quelque chose
de particulier qu'ils pouvaient me faire
entrer dans les retrouver oui mais la
fonction aussi quoi mais je crois pas
que je les dis souvent cette phrase même
aimé jacquet heureusement l'a dit lui
même c'est vrai que j'ai souvent eu des
accrochages avec lui parce qu'on n'était
pas forcément d'accord mais bon c'est
pas bien méchant mais les critiques
c'est comme ça on a été champions du
monde et on a une une période de
qualification pour l'euro qui a été très
difficile où on les disait il fallait
changer tout le monde
il y avait que des donneurs de leçons
les mêmes qui avaient critiqué mais
jacquet avant la coupe du monde et après
il était obligé de reconnaître que
c'était quand même un bon anglais a
commencé à critiquer le maire et vous
oui le maire évidemment dans la lignée
de jacques guéry certainement moi aussi
parce que bon j'étais un peu le
l'héritier de jacques et ont été blessés
par les propos d'un coéquipier qui a dit
en parlant de vous didier il est cramé
et le 2 septembre au dernier match donc
vous allez le voir et vous lui dites je
sais exactement les propos qu'il a tenus
sur moi voulait c'est qui ce type c'est
un des joueurs non je parie mais le fait
que je me sois éliminé c'est à dire que
j'ai laissé l'équipe de france
ouais ça pose plus aucun problème il
peut continuer moi je continue pas si
j'avais eu à continuer ça aurait
certainement poser des problèmes parce
que quelqu'un qui qui qui m'a trahie et
j'aime pas ça surtout de l'intérieur ce
que je vais dire oui évidemment on est
lui aussi le sait puisque j'étudie et
vous moi j'ai mis huit mois avant de
savoir mais je vais vous le dire c'est
qu'il est là ça
c'est pas possible
impossible d'ici là la wii joue en
équipe nationale mais discret parce que
finalement donc celui qui a dit didier
cramer on sait pas qui c'est là on n'a
jamais su ce que vous le disait s'il y
en a qui ont cherché un livret jeu les
gens lui sur lloris très mal ouais
sincèrement donc la cua voulu annoncer
que vous partez de trouver bourru là
têtus que plus de nom à une discussion
oui autour de ce sujet là mais bon
certainement pas j'allais pas annoncé
après oui dans le sens des sahraouis et
ça aurait été trop facile puis non
j'avais pas envie je voulais profiter ce
moment de bonheur avec mes camarades et
puis savourait surtout c'est là j'ai
vraiment savouré parce que je savais
c'est énorme
à la fin du coup de sifflet final que
c'était certainement un dernier très
grand match on avait l'équipe nationale
alors bon vous partez à valence l'a donc
problème physique évidemment comme de
confiance non avec lecteur kupper là ils
préfèrent par ruben baraja non comme non
mais ça a été lié il m'a fait confiance
dès le départ j'ai très bien débuté en
mois et demi et puis j'ai eu une
première blessure aux adducteurs en moi
je reviens il m'a refait jouer je me
robles là j'en prends pour deux mois
ouais donc j'ai été absent pendant trois
mois
l'équipe a bien tourné puis j'ai eu du
mal à revenir et il ya eu d'autres
joueurs qui ont joué qui aurait été bon
il faut l'accepter aussi mais c'est
surtout ma blessure qui m'a empêché
d'être compétitif et j'ai recommencé à
jouer ça a lâché encore un peu derrière
la cuisse et dragueur alors dites moi
j'ai encore deux ans de contrat là-bas
oui gérer ces deux ans quand là bas
c'est possible tout dépend pour la
première fois chez g 1
introduit dans mon esprit la notion de
plaisir par le jeu et donc j'ai pas j'ai
deux ans il me reste deux cents à jouer
et donc j'ai envie de prendre le plaisir
de jouer et donc si c'est pour rester à
valence est être assis comme ce soir ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup donc on verra
comment ça se passe quand cette saison à
scission du cirage
moi ya le soleil a lancé c'est pas
suffisant je sens que j'ai de l'argent
pour lui franck kitsch la fin de vos
jours le nom oui c'est bien payé le foot
la non la footballeur est très prisé le
football au niveau médiatique maries de
la mer
c'est vrai vous avez pas fait dans la
boue c'est que votre femme vous je suis
très bien là oui me convient et avec moi
je suis un mais ciel donc vous n'avez
pas fait dans la même qui nous non mais
je moi j'ai eu l avantage peut-être par
rapport à d'autres footballeur d'avoir
une vie avant cette victoire en coupe du
monde
donc bon je suis pas passé d'une extrême
à l'autre
ça a été plus difficile pour certains
joueurs qui sont passés d'une période où
il n'était pas très connu à être des
stars bien maintenant
didier deschamps concevez jouer avec la
juve
vous avez été entendu par un juge
d'instruction turinois pour des
problèmes de l'usaj de dopage maison de
créatine
qu'en est il exactement j'ai été
confrontée trois fois oui c'est vrai à
un juge d'instruction qui avant même de
poser des questions étaient persuadés
que
il y avait du dopage dans le football
qu'on utilisait le p o
donc c'est très difficile de
de faire face à un tel personnage la
créatine aussi c'est vrai qu'elle est
utilisée elle autorisée dans ces pays
certains pays dans d'autres noms j'en ai
pris pendant une certaine période après
j'ai arrêté je pense pas que ce soit un
produit nocif même si certains
spécialistes le disent mais le dopage en
règle générale et je pense qu'il y en a
dans le sport dans le football j'ai pas
été confronté parce que je pense
sincèrement je vois pas l'utilité
je crois pas que le dopage quand même
produit peut d'un
la joueur bidon de faire un super joueur
mais ça jamais fait tirer dans les
lucarnes je vois pas trop l'utilité ça
peut faire courir plus vite ça peut être
plus résistants mais il ya le ballon et
le balancer méfier il faut savoir le
diriger donc des matchs très souvent
même temps la répétition évidemment
qu'on a des aides
il vaut pharmaceutiques pour aider à
récupérer mais ce juge là il partait du
principe moi c'est ce qu'il m'a dit
enfin d'interrogatoire il me dit je
voudrais arriver à faire une loi que le
footballeur ci prend un produit une
vitamine c peut importe où on est
enrhumé ou qui prend quelque chose la
semaine avant le match il ne puisse pas
jouer un match
ouais il y aurait plus beaucoup de
football à la télé ça va bien merci de
votre sincérité l'innovation la question
qui tue
quant aux idées deschamps vous confirmer
c'est comme à la télé pas de dopage dans
le football
maintenant je vous faire tant pis pour
vous une interview nul en ébauche par le
single
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai peur comme celui baptiste volume
d'une batterie est convaincu convaincu
baptiste aussi cette famille de mon mari
va se marier
ah oui c'est une tradition familiale
d'alison chez vos convictions
d'accord je respecte toutes les
productions tout celle là surtout celle
là oui alors interview nuls dont j'ai
les questions très très con je pourrais
prendre au noir by ap après moi je sais
bien les poser je pensais alors est ce
que vous préférez pierre ou ginette
j'avais dit que c'était qu'on s'est on
parle des mêmes ouais parce qu'il va
beaucoup de meilleure énergie c'est
votre pierre pote papa pierre et votre
moment ginette non pas faire un choix
entre ses paras s'il faut avant tout les
deux c'est un formidable et 2 donc on va
pas choisir sincèrement vous arrivez pas
là non
entre hitler et staline vous préférez
acquis
vous en foutez c'est pas vos parents
séparés je vois pas de différence tous
les deux non ya pas de troisième à
choisir j'aurais ma faute c'est tout
mais c est pire encore bien alors vous
partez dans un vaisseau spatial pendant
trois ans je crains le pire
alors lire une île déserte avec qui
danser le vaisseau spatial avec qui vous
préféré partir cantona tapis ou locaux
récents problèmes au moins je vais
apprendre des choses
ah oui ça c'est sûr vous allez apprendre
des trucs de papa négativement on aime
on n'aime pas mais il laisse pas
indifférent ah oui c'est moi j'ai
beaucoup appris il m'a dit beaucoup de
vérité est-ce que vous préféreriez
mourir tout de suite là maintenant pas
vraiment et aller au paradis ou vivre
trente ans de plus et aller en enfer
je prends les trente ans pas grave après
on est sûr de rien après sont pas
d'accord et qui garde tu avais de les
heures car il allait bien c'est idéal et
de desjardins vous préféré partir avec
une fille très moche ou un mec très beau
pour aller à la pêche ouais alors la
pêche au thon
alors autant alors oui c'est dur ces
questions congrès c'est vraiment con
j'ai répondu comme un gant
c'est pas bon avec la fiq un fil très
moche ouais de taper des du tout
non vraiment pas n'ont pas non plus
vraiment sur cette île déserte peinture
y en a qu'on en parle à chaque fois si
vous partez sur une île déserte doit
être la même à mon avis parce qu'alors
les chanter là il avait fait sa
spécialité le saviez le nombre est avec
vous en arrivez pas merci allez les
filles qui envoient des emails deux ans
ce mois-ci samuel le bihan vu une fille
moche c'est si guillaume canet avait une
fille moche je suis d'accord vous feriez
quoi vous pariez fille moche ou m non
mais moi je m'excuse mais très beau
système
c'est la question
là je me laissais inverse j'ai pas je
vais pas à verser de leur équipe alors
qu'elle est moche très moche très moche
que la file très bon oeil un mec très
moche se trouve il est très intelligent
bon voilà fait très belle est forcément
très qu'on souhaite
ça m'arrange
bien c'est la télé vous préféreriez
adopter des jumeaux cleptomane des
jumelles pyromanes j'avais averti
cleptomane alors des jumeaux club thomas
oui parce que des gymnases pyromane dans
la région vous vivez en plus c'est mieux
que les petiots moi ça ramène des trucs
à la maison ça fait pas mal et je peux
peut être regardé en script de sega en
slip de tibéri ou en slip de delanoë en
fait pas un conseiller comme vous je
pense quidsi
[Musique]